bajo las aguas del mar báltico una parte
del futuro energético de europa está en
juego el gasoducto nord stream 1 abierto
desde 2011 está en el centro de la
atención tiene una longitud de 1.200 24
kilómetros una alemania con rusia y
tiene una capacidad total de 55 mil
millones de metros cúbicos al año en
2021 el 40 por ciento de las
importaciones de gas ruso a la unión
europea tránsito por este canal pero con
la guerra en ucrania el gas se convirtió
en una arma geopolítica el de junio
moscú ha reducido sus exportaciones y
durante 10 días planteó dudas sobre la
reanudación de las entregas usando el
pretexto de una operación de
mantenimiento ahora falta ver si el
suministro volverá a la normalidad
y
el gas llegará a europa a través del
nord stream 1 pero a juzgar por las
declaraciones del líder ruso lo más
probable es que sean volúmenes reducidos
quizás sólo el 40 por ciento esta
reducción no está justificada
según moscú un problema en la turbina
justificaría la ralentización del ritmo
de entrega berlín denuncia que se trata
de una decisión política el pasado mes
de junio alemania seguía comprando el 35
por ciento de su gas a rusia frente al
55 por ciento que recibía cuatro meses
antes una dependencia de la que muchos
europeos no podrán deshacerse en un
abrir y cerrar de ojos para responder a
un posible cierre de los grifos bruselas
se plantea imponer una reducción del 15
por ciento de las necesidades de gas en
los 27 estados miembros a partir de
agosto